Herkese
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
merhabalar Herkese selamlar sevgiler
Efendim
Hayat dediğimiz bu zorlu labirentin
içerisinde koşturmaktan zaman zaman
hepimiz yoruluruz heyecanımızı
kaybederiz bazen de farklı çıkış
kapıları alırız bugün burada farklı
çıkış kapılarına ulaşma noktasında
gösterdiğimiz çabanın emeğin bizleri
nerelere getirebilecek konusunda az ipte
olsa sizlere deneyimlerimi paylaşacağım
araştırmalarını söylediğine göre bir
çocuğun kişilik gelişimi doğumlu
birlikte başlıyor ve altı yaşına kadar
büyük oranda tamamlanıyor
Benim de bu evde yaşadıklarım kişilik
gelişiminde çok büyük etkisi varsa 12
henüz beş yaşında bir çocukken
dedemlerin köydeki evlerinin tavan
arasında bulduğu bir nesne hayatının
seyrini değiştirdi bir blok flüt
Ben hatırlıyorum da onu ilk kez elime
aldığımda çok fazla heyecanlanmıştım ilk
kez bir enstrümana dokunmanın verdiği
hazza anlatılmaz dıbı üflediğinde çıkan
sese mest olmuştum çok küçük bir
çocuktum Ama bu benim için belki de çok
büyük bir başarıydı o blok flüt öğrenmem
ve popüler bir kaç parçayı bütün Necla
etmen yalnızca bir saatimi aldı
zaten kendisi de müzikle haşır neşir
olan ve müziğin bütün tonlarını kendi
içerisinde barındıran bir ailede büyümüş
olmam da melodilere karşı farklı bir
yatkınlık duymamı sağlamıştı
bıo güçlü fark ettim Benim için bir
çıkış kapısı olmuştu müzik O günden
sonra müzikle uğraşmaya devam ettim
okula başladım okula başlayınca Okuma
yazmayı öğreneceğim için çok
heyecanlıyım Çünkü bu sayede müzikte de
kendimi geliştirmeye imkânına sahip
olacaktım ama bir süre sonra işler
istenildiği gibi gitmedi ben okuma yazma
öğrenme de Arkadaşlarımdan çok geri
kalmıştım herkes öğrenerek ilerliyor
Bense geride kalıyordu Okula gitmek
istemiyorum Bu yüzden çünkü okula
gidince çok farklı bir insana dönüşüyor
dum Oysa dışarıda rengarenk hayalleri
olan bir
çocuktum kendi kendime Kuklalar
tasarlayıp onlara roller veriyordum
flörtümle onlarca parça çalıyordum çok
güzel resim çiziyordum ama Okuma yazmayı
sistemin istediği gibi istediği düzeyde
öğrenemediğim için okulda kendimi çok
kötü hissediyorum okuldan içeri adımımı
attığım anda kendi yüzümü bir etiket
yapıştırıyor duk kendi kendimi
zekasından şüphe ediyor adeta geri
zekalı bir çocuğa dönüyordum okulda bu
beni çok üzdü
Bu elbette zaman içerisinde okumayı
istenildiği düzeyde öğrenme o Birazcık
sancılı oldu yıllar içerisinde de
müzikle macera hep devam etti ama ben
istedim ki okul sayesinde bir şeyler
öğreneyim okula rağmen değil Çünkü
yıllar içerisinde müzik derslerimiz hep
yazı yazmakla ve test çözmekle geçiyor
bu da beni çok üzüyordu
lise yıllarımızda geldiğimizde
Kardeşimle birlikte Bağlama öğrenmeye
karar verdik Çünkü içimizdeki müzik aşkı
bir türlü yerinde durmuyordu ama Bağlama
öğrenmek için ne yapabileceğimiz
konusunda bir fikrimiz yoktu
ilçemiz küçük bir yer olduğu için
bağlama satan ya da herhangi bir
enstrüman satan bir mağaza bulunmuyordu
Aslında bulunsa da bizde enstrüman
alacak para yoktu esas sorun buydu ne
yapacağımızı düşünürken düşünürken bir
arkadaşımızın emanet bir arkadaşımızın
eski bir bağlamasın olduğunu öğrendik
söylediğine dayısından kalmış çok eski
bir bağlama
O bize verebileceğini söyledi biz de bir
yerden başlamak istedik kabul ettik
bağlamayı aldık ama bağlama dediysem tam
mânâsıyla bir enstrüman değil telleri
Yok burguları yok eşi Yok hiçbir şey yok
Sadece bağlama formunda bir tahta
düşünün aynen o şekilde bir nesne bir
yerden başlamalıydı hemen bahçemize
indim ve kayısı ağaçlarının altına düşen
odunlardan aldım onları YouTube
bağlamamız a burgu yaptım eşik yaptım
şimdi bu sefer de Tel yok Ne
yapacağımızı bilemiyoruz derken
o Elimizin tavan arasına çıktım ve
oradaki eşyaları karıştırmaya başladım
ve ekledim içerisinden İşime yarayan bir
şey olur ve bir denk
bu
telefon kablolarının içinde bulunan
Ethernet kablosu dediğimiz ve renkli
renkli telleri olan
Evet şu kablolardan buldu
abone ol
var bu kabloya bakınca Siz ne
görüyorsunuz bilmiyor ama ben bu
kabloları bakınca umuda giden Koskocaman
bir yol görüyorum bu kablolardan turuncu
ve mavi olan kabloyu seçtim ve soydum
içerisindeki bakır telleri çıkardı sonra
otelleri bağlamanın altına taktım ve
sonrasında çalmaya başladım filtre göz
atıyordum ayarladım inanılmaz mutluluk
verici bir şey de o İkitelli bağlama
bizim o an bir çıkış kapımız olmuştu
yeni bir boyuta geçirmişti bizlere ama
istenildiği düzeyde ilerleyemiyor duk
sonrasında
12 telli bağlama ile biz öğrenmeye
başladık ilerlemeye devam ediyoruz ama
İkitelli bir bağlamayla ve tellerde
bakıyorlar Bir bağlama ne kadar
ilerleyebiliriz düşünüyoruz Başka bir
çözüm bulmamız lazım diyoruz
bugünkü bir kış vakti evden dışarı
izlerken kardeşimin sırtında bir bağlama
ile ve yaklaştığını gördüm herhalde
dedim hayal görüyorum Kardeşim eve doğru
geliyor ve sırtında bir bağlama var eve
yaklaştı gerçekten kardeşim içeri geldi
dedim ki kardeşim Ne oldu bağlama
nereden çıktı dur abi sakin ol
anlatacağım dedi rehber öğretmenimiz
beni yanına çağırdı dedi ki ben Duydum
ki abinle Siz bağlama öğreniyor musunuz
Ben de bunu aldım ama yıllar içerisinde
öğrenme hevesim kaçtı Evde boş boş
duruyor kabul ederseniz Bunu size hediye
etmek istiyorum dedi bana zorla hediye
etti Dedi kardeşim
ba ba My kılıfından bir açtık Aman
Allah'a gerçek bir bağlama telleri var
vurguları var ve mızrabı bizim annemin
etkileyen lerinden kestiğimiz bir mızrap
değil Gerçekten mi Mizrap O gün o
bağlama benim ve yüzlerce çocuğun
hayatını değiştirdi bazen yaptığımız
küçük bir iyiliğin nerelere kadar
gidebileceğini kestiremez büyük bir çığ
küçük bir kar tanesi ile başlamıyor mu
Ya da Coşkun akan Birsel düşünün bir
Damlacık suyla başlamıyor mu o da bizim
için böyle bir şey olmuştu
bu ve üniversiteye Geldiğimde yine
müzikle haşır neşir olmaya devam ettim
öğretmenliğe başladım yıllarda kendime
şöyle bir yol çizdim dedim ki ya benim
sınıfımda bir Veysel varsa ya bir Neşet
varsa ya bir Fazıl gözlerimin içine
bakıyorsa ya O zaman bunları keşfetme
noktasında bir şeyler yapmam gerektiğine
karar verdim ve bir pusula gibi olmaya
karar verdim öğrencilerim için
doğru yolu doğru yönü gösteren ve onlara
seçimler ve olanaklar sunabilen bir
Öğretmen olabilmek için çalıştım
sonrasında yaptıklarıyla Birçok insana
ilham olan minik notalar grubunu kurduk
ve müzik notaları grubumuzla yurtiçinde
ve yurtdışında birçok platformda
sahneler aldık Hatta ilk dedik
sahnesinde birlikte çıktık buradaki
sahneye bakar mısınız sekiz yaşında bir
çocuk sunuz ve şu sahnede siniz
karşınızda sizi izleyen dörtgen yakın
izleyici var ve orada hepimiz Şuna inan
bu Eğer bir şey gerçekten istersek
başardık ya da başarı bizim peşimizden
gelirdi
Bunu devam ettik
sonrasında
ve bu hayat çocuklarla çıktığımız
yolculuk birçok farklı yerlere getirdi
müzik notaları hikayesini Bir önceki
tediks konuşmamda bahsettiğim için
hikâyesinden burada ondan
bahsetmeyeceğim çocukların her birinin
hayalleri türlü türlüdür farklı farklı
düşünceleri vardır hayalleri vardır
bırak ama Eğitim sistemimizin iliklerine
kadar işlemiş bir tabir çocukların
seviyesine inmek gelin bunu birazcık yüz
eleyelim yüksek lisansımı yaptım
sıralarda öğretmen adayları ve
yetişkinlerle şöyle bir çalışma yaptım
arkadaşlar dedim ki onlara sizlere 549
rakamını veriyorum bu rakamlarla bana ne
isterseniz yapabilirsiniz dedim birer
tane A4 kağıdı koydum önlerine boya
kalemleri koydum ve beklemeye başladım
ilk yaptıkları iş A4 Ya bunlar bize
fazla hocam diyerek dörde bölüp kendi
aralarında paylaşmak oldu sonrasında
dakika sürdü sürmedi hemen çalışmaları
bana teslim ettiler vb şu şekilde bir
çalışma ortalaması çıktı gördüğünüz gibi
yetişkinlerin birçoğu bu rakamlarla dört
işlemi odaklanmış lardı farklı olan
birkaç çalışma olsa da genel olarak
eğilim bu yöndeydi sonra çocuklara
gittim çocuklar dedim sizlere 4 5 ve 9
rakamının veriyor bunlarla bana neler
yapabilirsiniz gösterin dedim
Çocuklar aldılar resim defterlerini ve
yapmaya başladılar bir ders saati
sonunda da onlardan çalışmaların
topladım şu şekildeydi görüyor musunuz
ne kadar sanatsal ve iç açıcı çalışmalar
bard 4 ve 5 resmin birinde Bulut olmuş
yağmur dokuz buldum içerisinden
yeryüzüne süzülen yağmur damlaları
olmuşlar diğer resimde ise
Ali Bulut'un içerisinden paraşütle
atlıyorlar 4 ve 5 aynı zamanda çocuk
yanına okşayıp yapıp paraşüt diye
açıklama gereği dönüş herhalde
anlayamayacağımız düşündü haklı olarak
Ama benim favorim şu oldu bu çalışmaya
bakar bakarsanız 9'dan 5 çıkıyor
39 giderken 5'in arkasından kovayla su
döküyor da
karşı taraf Mutlu
Sen düşünebiliyor musunuz burada çocuk
üç tane rakamla
sevgiyi mutluluğu hasreti ayrılığı
anlatmış
bu Burada sadece Al Yazmalım filminde ki
o kırmızı kamyon eksik sanırım o kadar
ki duygu yoğunluğu var peki şimdi tekrar
izleyelim mi bu konuyu Sizce Kim kimin
seviyesini olabilir Bizler hem
yetişkinler hem de Öğretmenler olarak
çocukların seviyesine ilmekten öte
yaptıklarımızla ve yapacaklarımız a
Onların seviyesine çıkmak için
ulaşmalıyız bence birazcık da çünkü
çocukların Hayal ufukları bizim tahmin
edebileceğimizi çok çok ötesinde
Bizler yetişkinler olarak her ne kadar
çok farkında olmasak da çocukların
hayatına çok fazla müdahil oluruz
bu Örneğin yeni doğmuş bebeğimize
tuttuğumuz takımınızı bana gelir işte
doğuştan falan takımı deriz
çocuğumuz pembe bir oyuncak beğen s
Hayır sen mavi olan almasın o kızlar
için der renkleri bile cinsiyete göre
ayrıştırırsınız sonra okul başlar
çocuklar okul bizim evimiz Yuvamız ama
bir saniye
Benim İstediğim kişiyle benim dünyada
oturacaksınız deriz sonra 23nisan gelir
Deniz ki Çocuklar Atatürk bu Bayramı
size armağan etti hepinize kutlu olsun
ama bir saniye bir saniye bizim
istediğimiz gibi Kutlayacak sınız Bu
liste uzağa gider sonunda da Bu karar
verme yetkisi elinden almış bir nesil
ortaya çıkar Sonra da biz Şöyle deriz bu
çocuklar neden Hayal kurmuyor neden
kendi planlarını yapamıyor neden gelecek
için yine de belirleyemiyor diye Yakınız
aslına bakarsanız
Çocuklar bizim onlara biçtiğimiz
hallerle değil kendi kurdukları hayaller
ve mutludurlar ve onlarla Kanatlanır lar
Biz o kanatları tutmayalım ki uçak
bilsinler bu
ama biz onların yerine konuşunca onların
yerine düşünce ve onların yerine düşünce
çok iyi bir şey yaptığımız zannederiz
Anadolu'da çok sık söylenen bir tabir
vardır insan evladının tahtını yaparmış
da bahtını yapamazmış
bırakalım balıklarını yapma yolculuğunda
kendi adımlarıyla ilerlesin ler bu hayat
hiçbir zaman toz pembe bir dünyadan
ibaret olmadı ve olmayacak da bunun için
çocuklarımıza sorumluluk almayı sabırla
birlikte mücadele etme yemeğinin yanında
olmayı öğretmeliyiz
Ama bu salondaki herkes Ben de dahil
olmak üzere yeni ve kötü ne manaya
geldiğini biliyoruz Değil mi ama önemli
olan nedir yeri geldiğinde iğnenin
yanında yer almak
en iyi eğitim bire yalnızca iyi doğru ve
güzel öğretmekle kalmamalı aynı zamanda
yeri geldiğinde iyinin doğrunun ve
güzelliğin Yanında olabilmeyi de aşağıya
bilmelidir
bizim için önemli olan çocuklara
çocuklar adına karar vermek değil
onların kendi yeteneklerini keşfedecek
alanlar sunmak
bak Aynı mahallede olan iki okuldan
okulun birinde çocuklar okulların Kapalı
Spor Salonu'nda yeni aldıkları
krampondan konuşurken diğer Okulda
çocuklar bu
ayaklarıyla ezdikleri meyve suyu
kutusuyla beton zeminde futbol oynamaya
çalışıyorlarsa burada bir kez değil bin
kez düşünmemiz gerekir aslına bakarsanız
son dönemde çok konuşulan beyin Göçü'nün
temelinde bu var çünkü
çocukluk yıllarımız dan beri
hayallerimiz umutlarımız
başka diyarlara göçmeye başlıyor yavaş
yavaş kendine yer bulamadı zaman başka
bir yer arıyor başka bir yol bulmaya
çalışıyor Beyin en son onların peşinden
gidiyor bir hayallerine sahip
çıkamadığımız bir neslin beyinlerine
nasıl sahip çıkacağız O yüzden çocukluk
yıllarından beri çocukların hayallerine
kararlarına önem vermemiz gerekiyor
hepimizin hayatında zorluklar var Şunu
hatırlıyorum ilk öğretmenliğe başladım
da
çok heyecanlıydım o örenci lere bağlama
çalıyordum gitar çalardım şarkılar
söylüyordum o sıralarda Bingöl Adaklı
ilçesi nde çalışıyordu çocuklar dediler
ki
öğretmen bize söylesenize Ben de halk
eğitim merkezi ile anlaşıp ilçe
tarihinde ilk bağlama kursu açmaya karar
verdi bu haberi duyunca hem yetişkinler
hem de çocuklar çok sevindiler ilçemizde
bağlama satan bir yer bulunmadığı için
para toplayıp bana vermeye başladılar
Ben Bingöl il merkezine gideceğim ve
oradan bağlamaları alıp geleceğim
arkadaşlar Hatta bırakın bir bağlama
mağazasına enstrüman mağazasında
ilçemizde o tarihlerde bir eczane bile
yok doktorun sağlık ocağında size
verdiği Reçeteyi ilçenin bakkalına
veriyorsunuz Bakkal yani ilçedeki
Eczacıya fax çekiyor ertesi günkü
ilçenin aracıyla ilaçların size geliyor
böyle bir ilçe Dolayısıyla paraları
topladım bir kış günü Bingöl il
merkezine en son alması yola çıkma
arkadaşlar sonrasında
bu zamanlarda olduğunu bunu yolda
gelirken alacakaranlıkta bir kış vakti
arabanın tekeri büyük Bir Çukura girdi
ve o anda kontrolü kaybettim ve
yıldızlarla göz göze geldik bu ve
saymaya başladı
dördüncü tatlı da oldukça Kayalık ve
çalılık bir yerde araba durdu
arabayla Takla atarken içerideki
enstrümanların hepsi bana çarpıyordu
direksiyona sımsıkı tutmuş vaziyette
Arabanın içerisinde dolanıyordu
sonrasında
dışarı çıktım bir ses duydum 70 metrelik
uçurumun dibinde Bana yardım edecek bir
ses yolla gelirken Arabanın teybi
çalışmadığı için telefonumu çıkarıp yan
koltuğa koymuştum müzik dinleyerek
geliyor O telefon Kaza esnasında camdan
dışarı fırlıyor ve karların arasında
saplanıyor ve oradan bir ses yükseliyor
çalmaya devam ediyor diyor ki gitme
gitme gitme kal bu şehirde
gitme
gitme yazık olur bize ve
bu sizi takip ettim ve Telefonu buldum
bu defa da telefon çekmiyor her yanım
acı içerisinde Elim yüzüm Kan içerisinde
yaşadığım ama emin olamıyorum kırık olup
olmadığına bakmaksızın bağlamaları
topladım ve uçurumun yukarısına
tırmandım arkadaşlar Aslında beni üzen
nokta bağlamaların kırılmış olması
değildi çocukların umutlarının kırılmış
olmaları Çünkü aylardır bugün
bekliyorlardı bir süre hastanede tedavi
gördükten sonra hayata Yeni Bir
Başlangıç yaptım ama bir şeyler yerinde
gitmiyordu oldu Sonrasında da öğrendim
ki doktorlara gide gide onların
tanısında şu sonuç çıktı bu bu hafızamı
kaybetmişim ama çocukluk yıllarıma
çocukluk yıllarındaki anılarımı
arkadaşlarımı Hiçbirini hatırlamıyorum
Doktorlar zaman içerisinde yerine
geleceğini söylediler büyük bir
çoğunluğu yapma yine de ilkokul
arkadaşlarıyla biraraya geldiğinde Bunu
fark ediyorum derse gittim çocuklardan
birisi dedi ki Öğretmenim siz sanki
Kazadan sonra eskisi gibi değilsiniz Biz
haklısın dedim Çünkü hafızamı kaybettim
böyle deyince çocuk da böyle biraz
üzüntüyle biraz da saf ve temiz kalbine
dedi ki Öğretmenim için önemli bir şey
var mıydı
de düğünden hiç Dışarıya çıkmamış O saf
masum yüzlü A3 Çakır Gözlü çocuğun
hafıza kelimesinin anlamını bilmemesine
şaşırmıştım gülümsedim sonunda bir ay
gecikmeli de olsa bağlama kursu açtık ve
oradaki öğrenciler çok güzel
performanslar gösterdiler Aslında
öğrencilerle olan iletişimimizi bu
noktada Çok önemli çünkü onları anlamak
için onların dünyasına girmemiz
gerekiyor bir gün çocuklardan birisi
dedi ki bana
Kocaeli'de çalışıyorum Bu sırada dedi ki
Öğretmenim ayakkabı bağlayabilir misiniz
Tamam dedim eğildim ayakkabısını
bağladım bağlarken arkadaşlar
ayakkabısını bağcıkları Sırılsıklam
olmuş bağladım böyle ben bağlarken de
Damlalar akıyor aşağıya doğru son düğümü
attım tamam dedim ki yarın Dışarıda
günlük güneşlik Ama sen bağcıkları
nerede sattın o saf ve temiz kalbi ile
dediki öğretmenin tuvaletten yeni çıktım
da Ne o Ne kadar normal bir şey değil mi
çocuk için işte biz de o normalde göre
bilmeliyiz Hayat dediğimiz bu zorlu
yolculukta yol ayrımları çıkış noktaları
birçok zaman karşımıza çıkıyor bazen
seçtiğimiz püf noktaları Biz bambaşka
yerlere getiriyor bu Yolculuk sırasında
tanıştığımız İnsanlar bazen bize destek
oluyorlar bazen de köstek olmaya
çalışıyorlar Bu hep böyle devam eder
Peki
neler yapabiliriz Yolculuk sırasında
bazen yolculuğu tamamlayabilmek için o
insanlarla yolculuk yapmaya mecbur
kalıyoruz Bazı insanlar çok iyi
temizlenmiş şeffaf bir cam gibidir
mesela onlara çarpınca ya kadar
karşınızda bir engel olduklarını
anlamazsınız bazı insanlarsa
ayakkabısının içerisine girmiş minik
taşlar gibidir Sizi çok rahatsız ederler
ama yolculuğunuz bitene kadar güvenlik
için o taşları çıkaramazsınız uygun bir
yer beklersiniz bazı insanlarsa bir
depreme benzer bütün yaptı en ileri
sarsarak yerle Yeksan etmeye çalışırlar
bu insanların Aslında Siz de bir
sıkıntıları yoktur onların üreten
Düşünen ve bilmekle yetinmeyip
yapabilmeyi Seçen zihinlerle problemi
vardır ve hepsinin ortak noktası
sizlerin ruhunuzu açtıkları yaralardır
ama Bizler gittiğimiz hedefe doğru
inancımızı sağlam bir şekilde tutup
yürümeye devam ederse koyarlar bir bir
kayboluyor Çünkü bazı yaralar ilaçla
bazı yaralar İnançla iyileşiyor
inancını ve heyecanımızı kaybetmediği
miz nice yolculuklara Çok teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]